is every title player allowed to enter
this
uh yeah as long as you're verified
or not verified is i guess a separate
thing now but as long as you have like
the title
um which is in some sense verified by
chess.com
playing jawspin
[Music]
i feel kind of bad
i mean
don't pre-move bishop e7
i feel kind of bad
josslyn's like a nice human being too
the other day i had two people
fall into this like back to back
uh okay let's not mess this up i have to
take the queen
probably king d2 and f3
i don't want to draw
there should be seven preventing
annoying knight checks
what's the material
i'll put this
king d7 is coming
i'm not even up a piece
no i am i can't count
how do i do this
okay i spent a lot of time there
but i am up a piece
it's cool to see josspin fighting from
a bad position
yeah i'm being extra extra careful here
start cleaning some pawns
ooh
why is my knight on each two
oh
hmm
okay yeah i feel a little bit bad but
um
it's not like it was a mouse slip it was
more like a
irresponsible pre-move high chats that's
actually impressive because
uh if we look at my
most recent clips video
i pl i got this in the game appointment
resigns immediately
and then
so
the very next game uh
i have confidence now
oh am i
here live
also thank you welcome back
good to see you back
oh this is so common
and my opponent resigns they're about to
resign
there
but it was cool to see like a strong
player trying to
to fight from
a very hopeless position